Les fédérales sont derrière
nous. On a donné un résultat
trop révoltante. On entre de
plain-pied dans les municipales.
Anie Samson et Luc Ferrandez se
bonsoir. Le combat entre Mme
Plante et M. Coderre, si l'on en
croit ce sondage, 500 personnes
qui ont été interrogées ce
matin. C'est chaud.
- C'est ce que je sens sur le
terrain pour me promener un peu
les gens avec les citoyens.
Chose certaine, au moment où on
se parle, dans la sixième
semaine qui commence, personne
ne peut prédire ce qui va se
passer. Honnêtement, personne,
je ne gagerais pas sur ça parce
que ça bouge trop. Les candidats
ont des positions tellement
différentes qui ne visent pas
toujours la même clientèle. Le
défi va être la sortie de vote,
ça va être quel clientèle va
aller voter parce que la
clientèle plus jeune, celle de
30 ans et moins, ce n'est pas
nécessairement celle qui va le
plus voté et c'est la clientèle
de Mme Plante. Tandis que de
l'autre côté, c'est l'équipe de
Denis Coderre.
- On l'a dit au fédéral, on l'a
dit lors d'autres campagnes, ça
montre que les campagnes vont
être importantes. La dernière
fois Monsieur Coderre avait une
campagne difficile. Il faut que
les deux faces une bonne
campagne.
- Oui parce que les masseurs
inquiétudes
le taux de satisfaction et à 40
% pour l'administration Plante.
Ce n'est pas suffisant pour se
présenter en héros. Il faudrait
au moins 60 % pour dire :
j'arrive et je vais me
débarrasser de cette personne.
Elle doit faire une campagne
positive et axée sur ses idées
et déposer des idées. Ce n'est
pas ce qu'il fait jusqu'à
présent. Il critique Valérie
Plante mais dépose pas de faut
qu'elle change. Il ne faut pas
qu'il fasse la même campagne
sinon il vaque à ses côtés.
- On les écoute.
DENIS CODERRE, candidat
à la mairie de Montréal, EM
- Écoutez, les sondages,
c'est sûr qu'on les regarde.
Je comprends aussi que seulement
33 % des gens seulement
qui veulent que l'administration
actuelle demeure. Il faut
travailler... et on n'a jamais
dit que c'était pour être
facile. Je vous l'ai dit depuis
le début que je ne prenais rien
pour acquis, mais je veux
qu'on fasse une campagne
d'enjeux.
VALÉRIE PLANTE, candidate,
mairie de Montréal, PM
- Et de l'autre côté, bien,
il y a une stagnation, j'ai
envie de dire même une descente.
Parce qu'au final, mon opposant
a perdu une dizaine de points,
ce qui est, somme toute, énorme.
Je pense que les gens réalisent
que M. Coderre est revenu en
disant : "J'ai changé, je suis
un homme nouveau." Mais je pense
que les gens... la balloune
dégonfle. Les gens se rendent
bien compte que c'est le même
bon vieux Denis qui fait le même
genre de politique un peu
à la pièce... au gré du vent.
- C'est Mme Plante qui fait des
attaques personnelles.
- Je n'aime pas entendre cela.
C'est une attitude que Valérie a
souvent eue en conseil. Elle est
très combative. Ce n'est pas le
temps. C'est le temps d'être et
de parler de ces enjeux.
Magnifiques propositions sur le
logement : il faut continuer
dans ce sens. C'est la que ça va
être intéressant de les
entendre, pas sur le crêpage de
chignon.
- Pas de que la Ballou ne
dégonfle.
- Les campagnes électorales,
surtout municipales, c'est des
campagnes d'idées. On sait que
les deux ne sèment pas. Chacun
est bon qu'un sauvegardant le
miroir. Ce qu'on veut, ce savoir
ce que les citoyens vont avoir
des plaies en votant pour ou
pour l'autre. Ça ne donne
absolument rien de faire ce
qu'ils font. Ça ne fait que dire
aux gens : rester à la maison et
ne pas voter. Il faut trouver
des raisons pour que le taux de
vote de participation augmente
en leur donnant des promesses de
choses qu'ils vont faire qui
sont réalisables.
- Mme Plante propose 60 000
logements abordables dans les 10
prochaines années.
VALÉRIE PLANTE, candidate,
mairie de Montréal, PM
- Si dans les années 80,
une mesure comme ça avait été
faite, je dis les années 80,
mais ça pourrait bien être 90
ou 2000, mais si une mesure
comme ça avait été faite plus
tôt, on serait déjà dans
une meilleure posture
que maintenant.
DENIS CODERRE, candidat
à la mairie de Montréal, EM
- La priorité numéro un,
c'est vraiment la question
de sécurité. Mais c'est la
sécurité de son logement
également. Donc, d'avoir un toit
sur la tête. Et puis on aura
des annonces à faire en ce sens.
- Il a dit par ailleurs que
c'était irréaliste selon lui.
Comment vous vous y cette
promesse année?
- Il y a une promesse qui a été
faite en 2010 et celles de 12
000 logements 6000 socialistes
e-mails abordables. Ça n'a pas
été atteint. Les 12 000 qui sont
là n'ont pas encore été
atteints. Quand je vois ça,
c'est de la poudre aux yeux.
C'est le marchand de sable qui
dit que les électeurs, il y a
des choses qu'on peut vous
donner. 60 000 logements c'est
beaucoup. 800 millions, c'est
sur Carentan et la logement sur
10 ans. 40 ans, ses huit mandats
électoraux. Aujourd'hui Mme
Plante s'engage pour les huit
prochains mandats à hypothéquer
les autres qui vont se présenter
avec un budget de 800 millions.
C'est immense. Sur les 12 000,
ça n'a pas fonctionné.
Actuellement, il y a encore des
gens qui vivent la crise du
logement qui sont hébergés dans
des hôtels. Au lieu de penser à
ce qu'on pouvait faire dans les
10 prochaines années, on devrait
régler le problème des HLM. Il y
a 500 HLM qui sont des logements
barricadés. Ils doivent être
réparés. Il y en a encore
ces beaux rêvés médianes qui en
ont besoin de mes matins.
- Vous désirez que cette annonce
formidable?
- L'enjeu de logement a
complètement changé par rapport
à il y a cinq ans. Quand Coderre
était en poste, on parlait de
logements pour les familles
démunies. Maintenant c'est tout
le monde qui n'est pas établi ou
qui peut avoir un problème de
logement. C'est très difficile
de ça Montréal. Il y avait 3
millions pour l'ensemble
dangereux de terrain à M.
Coderre. Non pas livré parce que
les blocages, mais c'était
imprudent de promettre sachant
que Québec et Ottawa est
impliquée. Pour les logements
qui s'en viennent, ce ne sont
pas des logements sociaux. Ce
sont des logements abordables.
C'est un principe, copropriété
du terrain, ou un organisme âgé
du terrain, construit et quand
la personne achète, il achète la
maison mais pas la valeur du
terrain. On remarque pour le
profit. Ce principe, c'est un
principe cumulatif.
C'est vrai que c'est imprudent
de faire une promesse sur 20
ans, mais c'est le principe.
- Vous aimez l'aider.
- Oui parce que ça existe
ailleurs. On a lancé dans les
années 80. Ça existe et ça a été
essayé. Je ne comprends pas
comment elle ne l'a pas fait
plus tôt. Tant mieux si on
commence. C'est imprudent de
faire de grande promesse à 800
millions, on voit ce début.
- Annie, il faudra que Monsieur
Collard arrive avec ses propres
propositions là-dessus.
- Définitivement. C'est une
bataille entre les deux. Le
logement, c'est une question
primordiale pour la campagne
électorale. Pour que les
citoyens aillent voter, il faut
qu'on compare les deux
programmes. Je regarde
correctement ce qui se passe.
Quand on lance de la poudre aux
yeux, et que je sais qu'il y a
des gens qui vivent à l'hôtel
parce qu'il n'y a pas de
logement, il faut mettre les
prêter aux bonnes places. Il
faut qu'on prouve qu'on a été
capable de livrer ce qu'on n'a
promis. Il faut aller chercher
nos citoyens par des vraies
choses.
- Merci beaucoup. On va
accélérer nos rencontres au
cours des prochaines semaines.
Merci beaucoup. C'est jusqu'au 7
novembre. Vous sera l'autr